sur public sénat
[Musique]
salut à toutes et à tous bonjour et
bienvenue dans sénat stream votre
émission de public sénat
chaque semaine on a le plaisir de
recevoir un sénateur enzi ou une
sénatrice pour répondre à vos questions
cette semaine on a l'immense plaisir de
recevoir victoire jasmin bonjour bonjour
vous allez vous ça m'a très bien et
bientôt installer tout va bien fait eh
ben c'est super tendu on va passer une
heure ensemble du corps jasmin on va
apprendre à vous connaître on va parler
de l'actualité du sénat et l'actualité
en général on va aussi parler avec vous
bonjour à vous bonjour le chat de
bonjour si vous ne regardez surtout
which bonjour si vous ne regardez sur
public sénat le canal 13 de la tnt c'est
dire vos questions que j'ai avec moi que
vous m'avez fait passer hier c'est bien
vos questions que nous avons en face de
nous ici avec madame la sénatrice et on
va pouvoir répondre à toutes vos
questions je précise d'ores et déjà que
vous êtes sénatrice socialiste de la
guadeloupe voilà on va parler de vous
refaire votre portrait mais avant je
voudrais qu'on parle un petit peu de
l'actualité l'actualité politique de
cette semaine c'est parti pour le moment
actu alors la grosse actu de cette
semaine on l'a appris lundi un petit peu
la surprise générale le président de la
république emmanuel macron a annoncé la
suspension de la campagne vaccinale avec
le vaccin
astrazeneca le temps que l'autorité
européenne du médicament que l'agencé
européenne du médicament est clair
visiblement un risque potentiel sur la
santé de ce vaccin là c'est une bonne
décision qu'il a prise
oui je crois way pour le principe de
précaution je crois que c'était
nécessaire de prendre une telle décision
compte tenu du recul suffisant que nous
n'avons pas concernant ont été validés
libre accès mais pour celui là et s'il y
a eu certainement des dysfonctionnements
et des fans et désirable c'était normal
alors coup quand même beaucoup de
réactions beaucoup de gens font
remarquer que l'on parle de 30 cas de
thrombose que c'est grave effectivement
sur 17 millions de vaccins le vaccine
rim est le principe de précaution vaut
pour moi je crois que le président dont
on dans une telle situation il aa pris
la bonne décision parce que les vaccins
de façon générale était déjà décrié
obtenu de l'antériorité de la prise en
charge de la population par les
différents axes 1
à craindre qu'il y avait déjà
antérieurement donc je crois vraiment
que c'est une très bonne passe 36
toujours 30 personnes crise 30 vies
humaines ce sont des personnes qui sont
aujourd'hui dans un état que j'ignore
mais pour eux-mêmes et pour leurs aux
autres et pour éviter les pertes de
chance donc pour moi je crois que c'est
une très bonne décision
une question de samy qui vous demande
très simplement comment ça va la
situation sanitaire en guadeloupe la
situation sanitaire en guadeloupe elle
est compliquée c'est à dire il est
compliqué parce qu'en fait on a des
mesures qui ont été prises dans un
premier temps pour le premier
confinement qui ça devrait être
peut-être en décalage donc c'est vrai
que il y avait une grande méconnaissance
de la situation dans laquelle on se
trouvait lors l'ensemble du territoire
national a été confiné et nous on a été
confiné en même temps à mais après on
enseignants bien rendu compte qu'il y
avait pas beaucoup de cash et non après
il ya eu un nombre important de cadres
donc toutes les personnes qui vivaient
sur le territoire mais sur les autres
territoires ultramarins vivaient de
façon différente la situation donc pour
ce qui est de façon singulière ce qui
concerne la guadeloupe
on a eu à un moment donné un pic au
moment où il y avait des baisses sur
l'ensemble des autres territoires en a
eu un pic et c'est la guadeloupe et
marseille qui avait évidemment connu des
situations particulières à ce moment là
elle notamment dit qu'on veut c'était au
mois de septembre à septembre le moment
là cette décision qui avait été prise de
façon conjointe par les élus il par le
préfet le préfet de région au sein d'un
comité de suivi
compte tenu des résultats
des plus en plus important qu'il y avait
concernant le diagnostic clinique et
hospitalisations donc aujourd'hui il y à
une véritable prise en compte de la
situation pour la population au vu du
nombre de personnes qui portent les
masses qui respecte les gestes barrière
il ya eu a fait l'année 2010 2020 des
opportunités d'aller en guadeloupe
justement parce que les chiffres étaient
libres était plutôt bon d'accord il
était plutôt bon et tout était ouvert
jusqu'à il ya deux semaines chez nous il
ya en fait n'en vaut environ depuis une
semaine on est on a encore le couvre feu
font parce qu'il y avait effectivement
des chiffres qui commençait à devenir
alarmant et il ya aussi une
problématique qui est lié à l'or il ya
ce problème là mais il n'en est pas qu
il y assure économique est déjà
difficile et sur les différents
établissements de santé que nous avons
parce que oui il ya une tension
particulière sur la sur l'infrastructure
hospitalière en guadeloupe oui parce
qu'elle s'était déjà c'était déjà très
fragilisé avec les 110 qui a eu en 2010
en fin 2010 est donc le mot moyen
nouveau chu qui est en construction mais
qui n'est pas opérationnel qui ne sera
pas dans l'immédiat donc c'est sûr que
les différents établissements de santé
publics et privés ont joué le jeu et
joue encore le g20 donc il y a quand
même une véritable prise de conscience à
la fois des différents partenaires de la
santé et des professionnels de santé que
je profite de votre antenne pour saluer
parce qu'ils se sont vraiment très bien
expliqué et j'en profite à mon tour pour
saluer toutes les personnes qui nous
regardent depuis la guadeloupe depuis
les antilles et depuis l'ensemble des
voilà des territoires d'outre-mer ce
salut a tous très très heureux donc donc
ici j'ai une question d'ailleurs à ce
sujet là en ce moment par exemple au
niveau de l'éducation par exemple
l'association d'un certain nombre de
parents alors il ya des fédérations de
parents d'élèves qui
et la majorité des parents d'élèves sont
d'accord pour passer pour faire porter
le masque à leurs enfants
et il ya aussi un certain nombre de
parents qui récuse cette possibilité
donc je me reconstruise avec qui est une
rencontre entre la rectrice et que l'on
passe qu'un des mesures ont été prises
pour les stores les enfants qui avaient
sept jeunes de pathologie et pour
lesquels et les médecins traitants ou
les pédiatres mais déjà pris un certain
nombre de décisions
j'avais une question de jeff qui vous
demande très simplement est ce que est
ce que vous vous êtes sentis oubliés par
la métropole donc dans la gestion de
cette crise et ce cabinet guinée mais
c'est l'ensemble du territoire national
lourd parce que cette gestion de crise
n'a pas été par n'a pas été parfaite sur
l'ensemble du territoire national
parce qu'en fait on quand on passe du
masque ne sert à rien on apprend qu'il
ya une certaine cacophonie ou agri table
mais au début on ne savait pas il n'y
avait pas beaucoup de masse mais je
pense que la vérité aux océans vie à la
population parce qu'il y avait toutes
les personnes qui ont pris après un
certain nombre d'initiatives quand ils
ont su qu'il fallait porter un masque
mais on a vu se multiplier les
initiatives à tous les niveaux et
concernant la fonction de look comme
métropole mais oui alors on voit nous en
particulier la difficulté complémentaire
c'est que ici sur le territoire national
on pouvait passer d'une région à une
autre d'un hôpital à un autre il ya une
diversité de possibilités de prise en
charge des patients y compris avec les
zones frontalières où il y a eu dans
certains cas on recourt à des hôpitaux
des zones constat liant ce que je
constate c'est que il ya eu une
centralisation des décisions
cette centralisation n'a pas permis aux
initiatives locales de se déployer dans
un premier temps et c'est regrettable
parce que dont il ya quand même les huit
pièces il ya un certain nombre de
professionnels de santé qui n'avaient
pas été mis en évidence parce que
c'était le taux hospitalier en chez nous
les difficultés sont liées aux hôpitaux
publics en premier dans un premier temps
de la mesure où il ya des limites du chu
qui est quand même le principal centre
l'archipel on est un archipel en plus
donc ça complique davantage les choses
et c'est vrai que on a pu avoir avec
santé publique france l'apport de
certains personnels qui sont venus à
certains moments pour renforcer les
équipes hospitalières
donc ça a été un plus on a eu également
avec l'armée les médecins me dis qu'est
qui sont venus donc il ya eu mais il ya
il a fallu quand même qu'ils ont encore
quand on arrive au plus bas l'un des dix
fils des situations du territoire et
c'est valable pour les autres
territoires aussi une question de the
drill qui vous demande comment ça se
passe les vaccins pour les départements
les régions en outre-mer donc tous les
vaccins donc il y a il ya eu dans un
premier temps fort pour ce qui concerne
la voile ou mais je pense aussi quand je
redonne un petit peu la presse dans les
autres territoires
il ya eu des réticences il y a eu des
peur parce que mon approche parce que
les populations particulièrement
guadeloupe
la population n'est pas contre vaccin de
façon générale de 160 questions d'art
tout l'effectif avec les supporteurs et
un centre moi même en tant que première
un fils de ma commune et des ligues ccsg
contribué depuis 2002 puis neuf à avoir
centres de vaccination dans ma commune
donc on est au centre de vaccination
c'était pour tous les vaccins
obligatoires de l'insee sur la partie
l'adhésion des populations mais vous
avez raison des doses oui mais par
contre par contre il ya eu au départ les
problèmes maloya les personnes qui
souhaitent se faire vacciner il y avait
pas encore les doses disponibles sur nos
territoires et maintenant qu'il y à des
doses mais bon je pense que astrazeneca
qui est un petit peu
décrié aujourd'hui et bien c'est un des
vaccins met à disposition sur nos
territoires
donc il ya eu un certain nombre de
centres de vaccination qui ont été
déployées avec l'accompagnement du maire
évidemment qui se sont très fortement
impliqué mais la question c'est de
savoir quelle sera parce qu'on ne sait
plus entre les premières doses une dose
unique après pour les personnes qui sont
qui ont eu le coup ville et qui doivent
aussi prendre avaient accès une deuxième
dose
une dose unique après maintenant en tant
que fonds isr propose trois doses et moi
je considère que au-delà de la question
avec senna c'est une question de coût on
est dans nos systèmes qui est compétitif
et concurrentiel et la question
financière également et à prendre en
compte dans cette affaire-là parce que
on est là dans une espèce de surenchère
avec un nombre de doses qui est commandé
initialement le nombre de gaulle tandis
que le fournisseur mon livre est donc en
fait là on est aussi dans une situation
qui est lié aussi à l'argent donc là je
pense qu'il ya aussi ces difficultés là
et je voudrais qu'il ya une certaine
transparence dans ses relations entre
les différentes laboratoire qui propose
des vaccins et l'efficacité des vaccins
en même temps
d'ailleurs j'ai une question de tomasino
qui vous demandent à propos du vaccin
cubain cuba a déclaré avoir plusieurs
candidats vaccins est ce que c'est
potentiellement c'est la question qu'il
vous pose une bonne idée pour la
guadeloupe
ça pourrait être bien que si toutes les
études comparatives me permets de deux
pour montrer où le démontrer que c'est
un vaccin qui a une certaine efficience
et une certaine efficacité pourquoi pas
voir qu'ils soient accumulés ou autres
délits qu'ils répondent à tous les
critères nécessaires pour pouvoir
permettre aux personnes qui
accepteraient de le prendre
d'avoir les anticorps nécessaires pour
se protéger ils n'ont pas pour avoir la
maladie parce que là il ya eu un moment
où il ya eu cette même date il ya un
doute en tout temps sur l'efficacité sur
l'efficience mais aussi sur la capacité
de certains axes qui sont mis en
circulation à protéger plutôt que de
diffuser la maladie donc c'est là si cet
écart là alors il faudrait des études
complémentaires évidemment il faudrait
les études comparatives également pour
savoir ce qu'ils sont de la partie des
articles qu'on peut lire
graphique on peut faire savoir ce qu'ils
sont ressortis du vrai du faux la promo
n'a pas le recul nécessaire donc la pop
la décision qui a été prise de stopper
pendant un moment mais je vois que c'est
cependant très peu de temps en attendant
que les experts donnent leur avis donc
on verra bien ce que ça va donner
il ya chaque kit qui voulez vous
demander comment ces mises en place la
réserve sanitaire pour le coc vide
comment ça s'est passé il ya une demande
de renforts de la part des élus on voit
le we weed la partie c'était très bien
moi j'ai eu par le passé parce que
j'étais cadre de santé
j'ai vu arriver lire qu'ils avaient un
cadre de santé au chu à l'époque
également pour les épidémies de daisy
cas de chikungunya en particulier on a
eu des réserves là c'était une situation
particulière là il ya eu des
professionnels qui était malade parce
que contrairement aux autres c'est vrai
qu'il y avait des personnes qui était
malade mais les effectifs étaient plus
ou moins stabilisé et un moment donné
parce que nous voulions pas répondre on
a eu pas mal
là il s'agit d'une situation qui est
particulière où on a besoin d ici sur le
territoire hexagonal de la plupart des
professionnels parce qu'ils sont les
hôpitaux sont exemple ci est bien avant
la pause il s'est rendu compte qu'ils
avaient des griefs qui avait quand même
des personnels qui est indigent
souffrance et kinés qui voudrait qu'il y
ait des renforts dans les effectifs
donc là ça n'a pas assez baissé de 7 est
valable également signe chez nous et en
guadeloupe en particulier et je pense
aussi à la martinique est là pour le
problème qui s'est posé c'est que entre
les personnes qui étaient malades qui
étaient confrontés à eux-mêmes ils aux
familles à part la maladie par à-coups
ville et les difficultés de prise en
charge liée également à l' expertise
qu'il fallait avoir parce que bon ce
sont les infirmiers anesthésistes parce
que la plupart des personnes qui
arrivera même si on nous voit un certain
nombre de lits de réanimation mais il
fallait qu'il ya les professionnels
formés et compétents est habilité pour
les prendre en charge et ce qui se
passait à ce moment-là on sait que les
professionnels qui étaient présents
étaient considérées insuffisantes pour
prendre en charge les nouveaux lits
parce qu'il ya eu quand même une
extension il ya eu
c'est un ou deux ventilateurs
d'équipements qui sont arrivés entre
temps mais pour prendre en charge de
façon urgente des professionnels d'une
part pratiquement tous les blocs
opératoires était en fait certains
professionnels des blocs opératoires
étaient déjà des renforts
voilà les animations une nation mais là
la quantité de professionnels et leur
permettre également de pouvoir souffler
parce que c'est des personnes qui
travaillent et qui n'avait plus les
mêmes rythmes comme d'habitude que quand
ils ont un planning bien défini donc il
a fallu effectivement qu'il y ait une
demande de renfort ça a été fait par à
la fois de façon conjointe avec entre la
rs et le directeur du chu on a eu encore
au massif également de l'ancien
professionnel qui était à la retraite
qui pouvaient également mes traditions
il ya une mobilisation et puis il ya les
professionnels également qui travaillent
dans le secteur privé ou qui sont les
infirmiers libéraux qui ont également
contribué avec le
les autres professionnels une prise en
charge mais ceci étant ce n'était pas
suffisant
certaines périodes parce qu'il y avait
aussi tous les points psychologiques on
pouvait rencontrer de certains
professionnels
donc du coup les réserve sanitaire et
c'était pas que les infirmiers il y
avait les premiers essais il y avait des
infirmiers anesthésistes un peut de tout
j'ai une question de comment sinon à
nouveau qui vous demande ce que vous
pensez du passeport vaccinale est ce que
c'est une solution pour l'outre-mer et
les touristes
non moi je ne pense pas que c'est
quelque part ce passeport vaccinale
serait en tout cas pour le moment moi je
suis pas favorable aux passeports
vaccinale parce qu'on a le libre choix
là je crois que avec caisse négatif pour
le moment on peut la voir c'est sûr que
au fur et à mesure je considère que
qu'il y aura beaucoup plus de personnes
qui seront immunisés il appelle entre
guillemets il a l'immunité collective
donc il ya les personnes qui ont eu la
maladie qui ont probablement encore les
anticorps donc qu'ils ont eu sans même
avoir des symptômes et qui n'ont pas
forcément tous les inscrits au club moi
je pense qu'il faut s'interroger mais
mettre en place un passeport au
vaccinale spécifique à la fois ça peut
peut-être protéger les gens mais ce qui
se passe c'est que les libertés
individuelles seront quand même
compromise même si certains moments on
peut penser que pour aller en guyane par
exemple on a le bac c'est le vaccin la
fièvre jaune par exemple mais mettre en
place un passeport vacciner ça va ce
sera le peuple est une contrainte pour
certaines personnes qui ne sont pas
favorables pour le moment tout cas au
vaccin
et il ya les personnes qui vont refuser
d'effectuer les déplacements dont une
pour le tourisme donc ce sera donc ce
n'est pas forcément la meilleure des
choses on va parler de vous victoire
jasmin c'est l'heure du portrait
alors une question que je pose toujours
à tous mes invités j'ai envie de
comprendre votre parcours comment est ce
que vous êtes devenue sénatrice on va
commencer par le début quel bac
avez vous fait alors moi j'ai fait une
formation de technicien de laboratoire
et les nouveaux mac cette recette pour
cette prime à l'époque on fait ce qu'on
la veille avait pas les maquettes et des
faits c'était à l'époque c'était céder
mettant cs et tout ça cette prime
à l'époque c'est donc c'était un box
était c'était société scientifique et
j'ai pas encore qu'il atypique parce que
j'ai quand j'ai commencé ma formation
j'étais dans une section 1 alors à
l'époque c'était plutôt littéraire et
c'est parce que j'ai fait certain nombre
de jeux de choix professionnel à
l'époque en fait parce que ma mère
voulait tomber le plus tard il voulait
que soient les filles ont bien que
j'allais passer des examens et les
firmes ya epinal vous vouliez faire ça
va faire quoi plus tard c'était ma
question quand j'étais enfant j'ai voulu
exemple est libre mais des choix c'était
une infirmière
c'était un enseignant pardon enseignants
et enseignantes ou religieuse ou
religieuse d'accord s'intéressant je
n'étais ni infirmière
[Musique]
c'est ma mère c'était une fille qui
s'appelait se constitue de laboratoire
et techniciens de laboratoire j'ai fait
cela ma formation à l'iut de créteil
ouais et je travaillais bon et après
j'ai fait une formation de cadre de
santé à l'école de cap de l'heure de la
rue de berri à paris et c'était l'école
de cadres de la croix-rouge et en même
temps de façon concomitante j'ai passé
aussi une maîtrise de santé publique et
j'ai fait ou d'autres issus d'autres
formations et j'ai eu aussi un titre de
biotechnologie médicale qui est un
niveau européen les produits proposés au
niveau européen pour travailler dans les
laboratoires donc après ben vous quand
vous sortez de vos études aujourd'hui
est ce que vous imaginez suivre des
études les études que vous avez suivi
dans les conditions dans lesquelles les
étudiants les suivent aujourd'hui non à
ce que vend la distance en vision vous
imaginez ça ml non parce qu'à l'époque
c'était 10 l'amstrad ça n'existerait
même plus aidé les ordinateurs de
l'époque c'était que les vues amstrad
vous comprenez conditions d'études
actuellement des essais concession
pensez vous auriez des études mais pas
comme un parc parce que c'est la vie
quotidienne cas qui se transforme
aujourd'hui c'est la vie cause c'est la
vie des étudiants à vis des familles
c'est l'avis de de tout à chacun en fait
outre vos études par vous auriez pu
aller au bout de vos études dans les
conditions
là maintenant c'est que les courageux
livre est courageux et motivés qui peut
continuer
parce que les personnes qui sont
aujourd'hui on voit dans le voilier
d'ailleurs les personnes qui sont
aujourd'hui à l'étude et qui sont
peut-être à proximité de leur famille
peuvent peut-être plus sentir mieux
parce qu'ils ont à la fois l'apport de
la famille est en fait au niveau
matériel et au niveau économique les
moyens de la famille en plus dealer
tandis que et les personnes qui sont
éloignés que je vois un exemple qui a eu
pour ceux qui étaient ceux qui étaient
au canada est ici dans l'hexagone et
bien un moment donné il a été question
sur l'hexagone que de fermer les
résidences universitaires et ont demandé
aux étudiants de partir avec leur
affaire si j'étais un peu libre la
ministre et de l'époque madame girardin
très rapidement parce que j'ai eu des
familles qui vont tout de suite appelé
j'ai été par le passé prison d'une
fédération de parents d'élèves et jeudis
en contact avec pas mal de parents et je
sais que ce n'est pas toujours évident
donc certaines mesures ont été prises à
ce moment là et va et les enfants qui
étaient par contre étudiants au canada
avait beaucoup plus de difficultés parce
qu'il avait pas de possibilité de retour
beaucoup souhaitaient pouvoir revenir
dans nos territoires soit la droite que
ce soit la martinique et pour ceux qui
étaient ici donc les associations il ya
eu beaucoup d initiatives individuelles
et des associations se sont impliqués
mais je crois que c'est le très fort
très compliqué et c'est pour cela que le
sénat a mis en place une mission
d'information sur la vie étudiante qui a
commencé il ya peu il ya une quinzaine
de jours elle s'est installée et je
cours je fais partie de cette mission et
je crois que là on va pouvoir mieux
comprendre les situations parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de disparités il faut le
comprendre
entre les étudiants en fonction de
l'heure de leur lieu
d'appartenance je dirais je ne dis pas
non plus parce qu on y suit le même
territoire national l'origine est sûr en
fonction des possibilités des familles
parce que quand il ya eu le premier
confinement il ya des parents qui ont eu
la possibilité de faire entrer leurs
enfants parce qu'ils avaient les moyens
de payer un billet d'avion d'autres sont
restés ils étaient tributaires ou bien
de leurs amis où il ya de la solidarité
donc ça c'est moralement c'est difficile
parce que j'ai eu au lendemain andro
change beaucoup de choses et et l'autre
chose alors la question des disparités
les moyens mais aussi la question de la
pauvreté en même temps parce que
beaucoup avaient des petits jobs
étudiants avait cette ressource
parce qu'ils pouvaient ou bien travaillé
dans divers domaines d'ailleurs et avoir
l'argent même quand ils étaient
boursiers pouvait avoir ce complément
est là ils se sont retrouvés avec
peut-être la bourse mais avec beaucoup
plus de dépenses et de charges et
c'était compliqué en plus mon lit et
proposer les commerces de proximité
n'était pas forcément à leur haut niveau
dans la mesure où on pousse on se quitte
en résidence universitaire ils n'avaient
pas forcément les moyens à la fois
d'avoir de cuisine et d'avoir des
ressources pour faire des courses au
fait c'était compliqué et je crois que
l'un avec les auditions qui ont commencé
on entend un petit peu les choses qui
sont mises en place et pompé simon vivre
mais je crois que c'est compliqué
beaucoup plus qu'avant les parce que la
solidarité aussi parce que les étudiants
entrent ils font de la solidarité
quelquefois ils peuvent faire ensemble
ont un parent ils peuvent se payer ces
ensembles les choses mais transformer ce
que chacun peut obtenir pour pouvoir ou
bien faire du coup sûr en tout cas pour
manger ensemble et là le fait de rester
isolé psychologiquement c'était
difficile pour eux mais aussi pour les
besoins du quotidien c'était compliqué
je reviens sur votre parcours à vous à
quel moment la politique est rentré dans
votre vie comment ça s'est passé
est-ce que c'était en famille est-ce que
c'était en famille oui d'abord parce
qu'en fait mais mes parents étaient
étaient des communistes avec sa part les
politiques à table
c'était non mais en fait c'était
communiste et j'ai tout le temps aller
livry journaux et je voulais vous
traversez transit et il pourra j'étais
souvent ces sept on colle assez marqué
ma tante et du coup ma mère il était
aussi impliqué mais moins s'impliquer
mais le fait d'avoir les forces de la
famille parce que mon nom que leurs
questions il était différent pour une
partie de notre commune pour le parti en
particulier celui qui allait être à
chaque fois qu'il y avait le journal a
fait citer les tesselles il allait
distribuer et nous on était dans l'isère
mais il y avait aussi une demi tonne qui
faisait partie d'une association qui a
été créée par madame l'avocate gerty
archimède l'union des femmes
guadeloupéennes dont la mère faisait
part de ses lutins - elle était moins
impliqué que sa grande soeur sa soeur
aînée qui était une militante et ma
tante qui était présidente donc lui ne
se faisait chez elle donc assez souvent
on se retrouvait dans un milieu où on
parlait pour ici compare les deux
situations liées à la situation des
femmes
on parlait évidemment d'économie en fait
un peu de tout et dont j'étais là donc
ça c'était le début après bon en
grandissant donc j'ai eu des cartes de
jeunes communistes
donc là mais en fait je ne sais pas
encore suffisamment impliquée j'étais
impliqué directement pas ma famille non
c'était familial met donc à un moment où
il ya une émancipation là ces victoires
qui le premier l'a mon premier choix en
fait je suis à lille vers les
écologistes parce que j'ai un ami qui se
présentaient à mon à l'eau dans ma
commune natale et qui m'a sollicité pour
ce qu'on est et on était très proches
alliés encore mais pas autant que qu'à
cette époque-là et
bon je participe à toutes les réunions
avec lui donc il m'a proposé d'être
socialiste donc j'étais premier
socialiste en fait en deuxième position
après lui et on a fait un score
intéressant 2001 mais parce qu
insuffisant tout car pour être élu
évidemment c'est la première fois et
l'ani diana d'après en 2002 j'ai été
suppliante sur sa liste pour les
élections législatives donc toujours
avec les verts libéraux a toujours avec
les écolos c'étaient les écologistes est
bon et c'est justement celui qui a fait
partie des premières plaintes à les
propositions pour la concernant le
concernant le concernant le corps
d'icône oui mais après bon j'ai fait un
autre cheminement passerait été prise à
son président de l'association parents
d'élèves parce qu'entre temps d'aller
les enfants qui le rendit son simplisme
la vie scolaire des enfants et c'était
mon cas donc j'étais président de
l'association de parents d'élèves
présidente de fédération de parents
d'élèves également sur toute la
guadeloupe qui était la première
fédération donc et j'étais donc le
réussissait quand même à concilier ma
vie familiale ma vie professionnelle et
ma vie associative est là après j'ai été
sollicité par justement un de mes
cousins qui faisait qui était l'élu et
l'équité élu local et qui était maire de
la ville a mis le monde à l'eau et qui
effectivement lui et elle est économiste
sur ce site et son père le communiste
très très engagé qui lui vaut à
solliciter lui il m'a sollicité alors
moi j'ai milité avec lui pour comme il
était devenu meilleur suite à la
démission du numéro un qui était l'amant
donc l'huile est devenue mère et
au moment des élections de 2008 l'aïe
cela pour une fois qu'il faisait
lui-même sa liste il a sollicité il m'a
sollicité donc moi j'allais
régulièrement toutes les réunions dans
les quartiers
bon je participais et au moment de faire
sa liste à fait moi je n'y ai demandé
mais je suis devenue la première sur la
liste
j'ai eu au départ je ne voulais pas
tellement du monsieur mettons dernière
tout ça parce que moi j'étais président
de fédération parents et tout est magie
mais non mais non mais là il avait vu le
travail que l'on fait parce que pendant
toute la campagne j'appelle méthodes de
travail donc je ne lis pas ce que je
suis devenu enfin il a et puis bon aux
élections nous avons gagné donc je suis
devenue la première adjointe au maire la
première adjointe de morale le monde à
l'eau et aujourd'hui vous êtes au parti
socialiste
oui alors il lui sera alors comme
c'était une liste ouverte mais entre
temps entre temps j'avais à dire est
jamais allé au parti socialiste entre
temps sa vie entre les verts et la jav
est allé au parti socialiste au niveau
national à l'époque avec désirs d'avenir
et 2006-2007 souvent hélas il y avait
une candidature à l'époque j'ai une
femme et moi j'avais trouvé que c'était
important que c'était ségolène royal à
l'époque d'accord donc c'est comme ça
que nous avons montré au parti
socialiste c'est comme cela parce que je
voyais que qu'il fallait qu'il y ait
aussi une femme en fait pour moi une
femme pouvait être présidente de la
république et l
comme elle avait été identifiée elle
avait décidé qualité candidate et j'ai
dit bon ça c'est quelque chose de bien
j'ai enchaîné question j'ai une question
qui vous est posée par par trois nuls
qui voulez vous demander ce que le parti
socialiste est toujours socialiste
les partis le parti social milliards
est-ce que vous portez sur le
quinquennat des veines de françois
hollande est bien mais françois hollande
il aya travail on n'a pas suffisamment
mis en évidence le travail qui a été
effectivement réalisées par cette
mandature
parce qu'il y avait évidemment les
fondeurs il ya eu en fait c'est ça c'est
dissocie et discret qui mêle c'est
dommage mais il ya un certain nombre
d'actions qui ont été munies pas à la
fois par le gouvernement enfants sera
hollande par ces ministères au niveau de
la niveau de la santé il ya bon hugo
certains noms mais au niveau de la
sécurité également parce qu'il faut
savoir que l'ancien ministre de l'étude
quitté après ministre de magasins casino
dont il ya quand même mais il a quand
même très bien travaillé moi ce que je
regrette c'est que au niveau du parti
qui ait eu des questions des coups qui
ont pas qu'ils auront un petit peu
perturbé l'organisation des choses mais
je pensais bien que françois hollande il
a fait il a fait le travail qui n'a pas
suffisamment été valorisés parce que les
fondeurs ont fusé questions de
valorisation sa cause des frondeurs que
ça rentre parce que m il y avait un
travail qui est fait mais lui aussi pour
il fallait peut-être qu'il y ait plus en
interne même plus de cohérence entre les
uns et les autres mais je ne vais pas
porter de jugement de valeur n'était
même pas ce que je n'étais pas à
l'intérieur pour voir comment les choses
se déroulent un mais je crois que c'est
c'est là c'était un parti au il y à il y
a des valeurs
il ya des valeurs socialistes donc je
pense que les personnes qui sont
socialistes même quand elles sont
parties peut-être ailleurs ou ceux qui
sont restés il ya toujours le côté et du
social qui prime
qu'elle soit pensée parce que quel que
pense l'ancien communiste et l'ancien
écologistes que vous êtes d'un certain
nombre de personnes à gauche qui refuse
de faire alliance avec le ps en estimant
que le ps n'est plus de gauche le ps
s'est noyé dans une social-démocratie
macron compatible voilà moi je suis une
démocrate je comprends que certaines
sources on retrouve pas dans le parti
socialiste les joueurs respectent le
choix parce que mon emmanuel macron il
était à l'intérieur du parti aussi donc
marquons compatibilité à l'intérieur il
faut cela choisi pour faire un travail
après il a fait le choix qui était le
sien il que je respecte parce que nous
sommes encore dans un système
démocratique donc emmanuel marc un parti
mais c'est sûr que les personnes qui
étaient à ses côtés sur les bancs des
socialistes c'est sûr qu'il ya eu
certain nombre de liens qui se sont
tissés et c'est certes est sympathique
avec avec lui parce que lui il avait une
autre projet parce qu'il est bon donc là
moi je respecte le choix de chacun parce
que le parti de feu actuellement de
monsieur marc aumont tous ceux qui l'ont
fondée et pour la plupart ce sont des
socialistes déjà ce nom c'est le chemin
de rome et les personnes qui veulent
encore rester au niveau au parti
socialiste et qui veulent faire du parti
socialiste le parti
qui a ses propres valeurs qui veut
rester socialiste ça ne me dérange pas
ça me dérange pas parce qu'on doit
respecter les choix de chacun qu'est ce
que vous pensez de l'union de la gauche
qui c'est qui a été annoncé dans la
région des rôles taux des oat france
pour les aider pour les élections
régionales de juin prochain
est ce que vous pensez qu'une union de
la gauche est souhaitable pour 2022
peut-être oui oui oui parce qu'on
regarde un petit peu les choses je suis
allé un peu jusqu'à mitterrand c'est
grâce à l'union de la gauche
là c'est grâce à l'union de la gauche et
la gauche a refait les différents partis
de gauche sont complémentaires ils sont
complémentaires donc ils peuvent se
mettre ensemble ils s'entendre pour
défendre des valeurs
alors certes certains peuvent penser que
ce n'est pas possible moi j'y crois
votre serment
parce que ce sont des personnes qui sont
complémentaires en termes de personnes
mais en termes de valeur égale ment donc
j'y crois et je crois que c'est une des
solutions si on veut effectivement il
changer ça suffira à empêcher un second
tour macro le pen union de la gauche
là je ne fais pas plaisir je ne sais pas
si ça dépendra d'eux
du travail qui sera fait le travail de
proximité de compréhension et maintenant
la situation sanitaire ne facilite pas
forcément ce travail là mais là tout est
encore possible parce qu'il y à encore à
démontrer pense qu'il ya eu des
défaillances et il ya eu des situations
où on récupère m en tout cas à la
population de de faire d'autres choix
que que le choix mme marine le pen
macron bon on verra on va pas prédire
l'avenir en 2017
emmanuel macron était lui présent la
république et vous étiez élue sénatrice
on va parler de vous au sénat c'est
l'heure du moment c'est nord alors
d'abord première question comment ça
s'est fait votre élection en tant que
sénatrice vous étiez maire de morne à
l'eau à son moulin
non j'ai dit si tu as un virage et à
fournir la société première adjointe
dans le sud j'ai été 3e adjointe et
après j'étais encore première adjointe
et la jcat première adjointe et là
j'étais sur une liste j'ai été sollicité
par l'ancien ministre
victorin lurel il m'a dit que je faisais
partie des personnes qui souhaiteraient
avoir sur sa liste je me suis intéressé
j'ai vu mais l'essai combien de
personnes on fait comment pour
comprendre parce que je n'étais pas du
tout au départ expliqué j'ai pas que
cette dynamique là et j'ai vu que cette
personne avait que la partie donc dès
dimanche l'as bourgeais socialisme ne
sait pas tout vraiment et c'est bon il
m'a appelé je crois trois fois pour me
dire mon âge j'ai été sollicité par
plusieurs autres candidats c'est vrai et
un jour il m'a appelé pour me dit qu'il
y avait une réunion pour la présentation
des listes qu'il avait finalisé est bon
qu'il avait vu avec eux au niveau du de
son parti et qui était le mien de toute
façon et il fallait il y avait une
rencontre et c'est le jour de la
rencontre avec la presse en fait mais je
que j'apprends que je suis deuxième sur
la liste mais parce que vous n'aviez pas
que vous étiez deuxième sur la liste
rassemble il a plusieurs choix il est la
personne qui en fait la wii mais je vous
dis j'étais nos vies parce que je savais
que nous étions deux femmes
jamais des informations comme ça et
aussi ce jour là les juste avant il ya
eu là une réunion est la deuxième femme
quittée sur la lys et la présidente du
conseil départemental qui a fait le
choix
en fait elle était probablement
pressenti pour être juste la buse m
mais elle a fait le choix de pousser
comédie de pousser la liste et
elle a souhaité rester comme il était
président du conseil départemental
rester à 100 donc du coup je me suis
retrouvé le deuxième et après le
l'élection eh bien on a eu un très très
bon score est donc vous assure patrice
gélard suis devenu lycée les attriste
pas sur cette liste j'ai une question
pour vous de shiso qui vous demande tout
simplement comment s'organise votre vie
entre le palais du luxembourg à paris
dans le 5e arrondissement et la
guadeloupe
oui eh bien je fais il en aller retour
en avion par an que je fais je fais des
va-et-vient avant j'essaye de faire
l'utile et l'agréable dans la mesure où
les deux sont utiles c'est vrai mais en
fonction de l'agenda à la fois à paris
du sénat parce que je suis la commission
des affaires sociales donc je sais que
dont il ya des périodes quand on parle
du plfss donc jaurès à paris finançons
la sécurité sociale de votre commission
travaille dessus
en gros l'automne vous êtes à paris
jaurès et ce quand je passais pour
décontaminer mais si les contrer c'est
un inter d'aujourd'hui concernant
accepté du tout c'était nationale ce
serait difficile difficile et compliqué
parce que là la contrainte c'est déjà à
chaque fois faire le test pcr il jusqu'à
maintenant grâce à dieu je dis j ai
testées négatives je ne fais pas
fréquemment le test est négatif et aussi
donc faire le va et vient d'obliger le
limité quand même les allées venues tout
on pense qu'il ya moins d'avions c'est
vrai mais je je je je
en fonction de l'ensemble à l'agenda du
sénat parce que je suis très impliqué et
maintenant encore plus parce que je suis
secrétaire du sénat
mais oui la secrétaire du sénat
absolument février donc en fonction
alors il ya cela et il ya je suis la
délégation des droits des femmes et de
la délégation d outre-mer donc si fait
que en fonction des sujets en fonction
de l'organisation alors c'est vrai que
nous pouvons travailler en
visioconférence pour sceller les
délégations et pour les commissions
quelquefois il la plupart du temps
maintenant parce qu'il y a quand même au
sénat compte tenu des règles
distanciation il y va ça me tire tout
simplement donc tout le monde ne peut
pas être un prison en même temps donc il
ya une organisation qui se met en place
donc je suis mais quand même j'ai une
possibilité mais faire le va-et-vient je
le fais souvent la loi
je crois que nous y serons nous à lait
venus mais je ne nie pas forcément
filles et 12 par an
parce que c'est aussi une grosse averse
qui a doucement
oui en fait il ya un budget sans visage
un billet d'avion officielle voilà et en
fonctionnaires peuvent fluctuer les prix
peuvent fluctuer on peut aller jusqu'à
200 ce qui voudrait dire que par mois
mais il est vrai que moi je quelquefois
je la conseille à la fois que vous étiez
en guadeloupe et bien j'étais en
guadeloupe jusqu'à il ya dix jours il ya
dix jours et c'est quand la prochaine
fois que vous y retourner alors je
devais partir la fellation de cette
semaine il ya qui sont qui sont
modifiées il ya certains impératifs
donc en fait là donc se lasser et s'est
avancé à moi je suis très content que ce
soit sur mon plateau alors non ce
passage à paris
c'est très bien j'ai une question de
better auteurs qui vous demandent est ce
que ça vous arrive parfois de vous
sentir discriminés en tant que sénatrice
des outre mer au sénat où est ce que il
n'ya pas ya pas d n'y a pas de débat les
sénateurs métropolitain est tiré d'un
terril trois marins sont sur un pied
d'égalité
je travaille très bien avec tout le
monde à la fois au sein de mon groupe à
la fois haussé les autres groupes donc
je ne me suis pas sentie discriminée je
suis quand même à l'aise très à l'aise
au sénat et je tiens je profite
justement de l'occasion pour remercier
et féliciter le professionnalisme des
personnels du sénégal fonctionnaires du
sénat sont des personnes qui sont
extraordinaires donc à aucun moment je
n'ai ressenti une différence de
traitement à aucun moment je n'ai non
parce que bon je fais mon travail avec
la rigueur qui s'impose
et quand j'ai besoin d'avoir des
informations je ne mendie j'ai toujours
les réponses et au en tout cas mourinho
vers les personnes les plus
opérationnels comme répondent donc moi
je n'ai pas de souci par rapport à cela
on va parler d'un sujet sur lequel vous
êtes très engagé évidemment la
chlordécone
on l'a appris aujourd'hui le parquet de
paris le procureur a l'intention de
classer sans suite le la plainte pour
raison de prescription les délits
seraient prescrits j'imagine une grande
déception
delattre ancien élu golden week l'élu
mais c'est toute la population d'avoir
loupé de la martinique
parce que depuis tantôt il a j'ai fait
partie des vo guadeloupe à l'époque avec
monsieur email et à l'époque où il a pu
aussi s'appeler c'est vrai que
liliane déception il ya parce que j'ai
posée il ya quelques jours il ya une
question au gouvernement concernant ces
problématiques parce que jamais une
information et je souhaitais poser cette
question c'est vrai qu'il y a une
liberté je dirais du tribunal donc là ce
n'est pas le ministre qui m'a répondu
c'est le ministre de la santé qui m'a
répondu adroitement et qui a reconnu
quand même que c'était une saloperie la
cour d'école aujourd'hui il y à un
certain nombre de familles parce que ce
n'est plus utilisé c'est vrai mais qui
vivent l'écho des conséquences seraient
désastreuses au niveau de la santé il ya
des personnes qui sont décédées à cause
de ce produit pour lequel il y a eu des
dérogations particulières et la gelée
évoqué lorsqu'il ya eu la dérogation
pour les néonicotinoïdes ici peut-être
que c'est à une autre échelle j'en sais
rien l'avenir nous le dira mais le
principe des dérogations alors que les
produits sont sortis de là l'utilisation
moi ça me pose un sérieux problème donc
maintenant on a des enfants des petites
des petites filles qui ont des problèmes
hormonaux considérable il ya des
problèmes endocriniens
il ya un certain nombre de dogmes qui
ont eu des cancers de la prostate entre
autres mais il ya aussi d'autres types
de pathologies qui sont écrites mon pour
lesquelles si pour certaines il ya des
liens de causalité qui ont été faites
pour d'autres bons on ne sait pas
forcément mais il y a
c'est une vrai problème que ce ce qu'il
y ait cette prescription
c'est un vrai problème est là je ne vais
pas porter je ne me permettrais pas non
plus de porter un jugement concernant
les décisions de justice mais je dis que
pour les personnes qui étaient en
attente d'une réponse beaucoup plus
adaptés plus adéquate par rapport au
préjudice subi
et bien c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
dommage on m'a arrêté là je ne pensais
pas de jugement toutefois il ya un plan
d'accueil iphone 4 qui arrive et moi je
suis contente d'avoir signé un protocole
en cours qui rien protocole voilà donc
ça commence il ya une référence qui a
été désigné et avec les associations
avec les élus est un travail qui se met
en place
je suis quand même très heureux d'avoir
pu l'année dernière vous proposer un
amendement qui a été adopté sur le
principe du diagnostic diagnostic
biologique pour le chlordécone pour la
prise en charge les deux mètres la mise
en place d'un budget fléchi et je crois
que là ça et essayer aussi en profiter
en première lecture au sénat parce que
j'avais proposée cet amendement l'as
maintenant les choses se font
progressivement mais je regrette
vraiment
qu'il y ait une prescription j'ai une
question de red tails qui vous demandent
est-ce que vous pouvez nous parler du
prix de la vie aux antilles on en est ou
du prix de la vie on est bien je suis
posé de bonnes questions là dessus de
travailler d'essayer de causer davantage
parce que les puits sont 30 30% plus
cher 30 à 40% en fonction des produits
plus chers et si les personnes qui
viennent en guadeloupe et qui ont
l'habitude de consommer un certain
nombre de produits ici quand ils
arrivent ils sont ils sont étonnés donc
ils changent leurs habitudes ils
prennent peut-être d'autres choses oui
absolument et de produits qu'ils
n'achètent pas donc il y a
là il y as depuis 2009 où il y avait eu
un mouvement social important
walou puis à la martinique mouvement de
cap il ya eu effectivement des mesures
qui avaient été mises en place
concernant les prix les choses ont bougé
aujourd'hui les choses n'ont pas
franchement mozilla suis en train de
travailler sur la question faut bien
comprendre parce que il n'y a pas bien
longtemps on a parlé de la taxe qui
s'appelle l'octroi de mer qui est sûr et
d'appliquer sur nos territoires celui
qui sur ces préjudices
quand même à la fois sur la production
locale enfin et c'est là dessus que les
produits les produits manufacturiers cet
homme de poésie qui arrive sur nos
territoires dans lesquels il ya une taxe
mais les produits locaux c'est à dire
que si vous acheter de la farine
alors il ya la farine de froment la
farine qui vient d'ici cette farine et
taxés quand on est amis l'ont pas loupé
mais le pâtissier qui va transformer qui
va faire par exemple y croire sans autre
chose et bien il y aura une taxe sur les
produits transformés
donc là c'est ce qu'il faut
l'organisation soit différente au niveau
de l'utilisation des projets locaux il
ya des personnes qui ont il ya eu
beaucoup d'initiatives d'ailleurs
pendant la période covidien de
confinement particulièrement où les
bateaux il n'y avait pas le cabotage qui
était fait de la même manière il ya donc
là il ya l'aiguillé cet homme
d'initiative et qu'ils aient de son
entrée de devenir des initiatives
pérenne mais je crois que la question de
la construction du prix parce que là il
ya une liste de produits de première
nécessité fléchi était clairement
identifié et quand on regarde bien j'ai
l'impression et la gestion travaille
dessus sommes ici dans l'hexagone et à
trois interlocuteurs trois opérateurs
qui entre le produit tel qu'il est
faye et jusqu'au consommateur dans le
marc de café je suis le marché mais
aussi dans les épiceries swan proximité
ou les grandes surfaces
il ya trois opérateurs pour la
guadeloupe la martinique et je pense que
si c'est probablement la même chose pour
les autres territoires
il y en a 14 et les fred approches sont
amplifiées et c'est cela les produits de
première nécessité qui sont utilisées et
qui sont dans la liste l'un est bien les
personnes qui les utilisent qui n'ont
pas tellement de choix parce qu'ils ont
besoin de ces produits là ce moment là
ce sont ces gens là qui pèsent sur les
personnes les plus démunies en fait qui
payent le toucher les intermédiaires sur
les médias là il ya un intermédiaire en
plus et là c'est une question tout aussi
en train d'étudier je fais j'essaie de
livres à nous comprendre et à un des
intermédiaires qui fait le cabotage qui
sort de l'hexagone pour venir vers les
antilles et qu'ils sont bons exemples en
fait là où il ya tous les containers et
qui dépose apprécié certains containers
pour avoir loupé identifiés et commandé
par les guadeloupéens par les
entreprises guadeloupéennes
maintenant compte tenu que pour
peut-être optimisé j'en sais rien il va
aussi le même vélo c'était à l'époque où
le président chirac avait carrément je
dirais le pacd mais en tout cas il avait
accepté que ce soit une cette compagnie
particulier qu'ils aient le monopole
plus ou moins et aujourd'hui on se rend
compte que il dépose des que certains
contenir en guadeloupe et compte tenu
des impératifs des autres ports de la
caraïbe qui ont une autre organisation
et qui met son pays où il ya un planning
à des heures les dates précises et des
heures précises et bien cet opérateur
s'il n'a pas fini mais pour éviter de
retard sur le timing qui lui est réservé
dans certains ports de la côte report eh
bien il repart avec les produits
destinés à la matinée et il va sur la
carte
et là ils déposent les containers là
donc il faudrait qu'il y ait un autre
qui reprennent pour retourner alors
qu'il est venu deux fois du coup c'est
ça qui payent pour l'om la jeune et
pauvre en tunisie pour iphone mais en
fait quand on est en tout cas donc tout
ça participe en titre et vu énormément
en plus il ya de transit parce que sur
il ya là les transitaires il ya les
transporteurs les transporteurs l'a fait
il ya eu en plus pour certains produits
qui sont stockés parce qu'il ya des
poésies qui sont stockés en fonction de
leur date limite d'utilisation on a une
marge donc là quand il met dans son
container ça va rester dans un lieu
précis et tout sera donc il faut aussi
d'optimiser il ya des frais
il ya des fois des approches qui sont
beaucoup plus importantes donc la
réalité c'est quand ça donc c'est
toujours très cher une question de l'omi
qui vous demande votre avis sur le
problème de canalisation d'eau oui c'est
un vrai problème il dit c'est entre
c'est en très mauvais état c'est très
mal géré et qu'est ce que vous en pensez
oui oui allons j'ai eu l'occasion de
m'exprimer pas facile pour mixer la
mairesse amont sénat parce qu'il ya une
proposition de loi de deux autres
collègues parlementaires
gse situation donc c'est une situation
qui est désastreux c'est vrai et là on
se rend compte que il y a eu plusieurs
mais je dis bien plusieurs personnes
physiques et morales je dirais comme
cela qu'ils n'ont pas fait au moment il
fallait ce qu'ils devraient faire
la mesure où laisser les canalisations
sont arrivés dans cet état là c'est que
d'une part ceux qui étaient en charge le
fait qu'ils avaient des délégations de
service public pour le faire ne l'ont
pas fait pour les entreprises qui
devaient les entrées du quartier qui va
venir faire ce sont des plus calmes et
des délégations de service public la
première chose
certains élus qui était en charge du
dossier parce que bon la ja les
entreprises n'ayant si les élus certes
c'est lui qui avait en charge dossiers
qui ont laissé faire parce qu il
on paie pas suffisamment tous les sens
mais aussi les entreprises qui étaient
là qui pouvait il peut être les écoliers
ne l'ont pas fait et il ya aussi je dis
et je le dis on la dernière fois je lui
dis aux ministres qu'il m'a dit que mon
le contrôle de légalité vinifie mais je
dis que le contrôle de la légalité on
doit payer à tous les niveaux les
services fait hélas le service n'a pas
été fait et ce sont les entreprises qui
ont quand même bénéficier de paiements
parce que où qu'on avait quand même
aujourd'hui
ensuite ils ont foncé qui ont des lits
aux indignés alors il ya eu des points
est donc là je laisse la justice faire
son travail
il ya des précédents nombre de plages et
il ya sept membres d'associations qui se
sont formés depuis tantôt donc en
guadeloupe en fait le problème qui se
pose c'est qu'il ya beaucoup plusieurs
opérateurs
il ya plusieurs difficultés
et maintenant donc la proposition qui a
été faite pour répondre à toutes les
difficultés si elle avait été faite de
façon conforme par rapport à l'ensemble
des 10 km 10 pc et les exécutifs pour le
moment il ya deux ans et moore qui sont
venus décriée par le département la
région et les apc de nos territoires
sauf bagarre pour le moment parce qu'on
est un archipel si un petit peu
compliqué à ce stade et un autre qui a
été créée par la loi
donc ce que je regrette en tout cas
c'est que les guadeloupéens ils on
souffre donc voilà il ya deux il faut il
faut aussi dissocier de choses parce
qu'il ya de l'eau de captage et c'est
surtout ceux qui sont desservis en eau
de captage qui ont ces difficultés là où
il ya de l'eau de forage en a moins de
difficultés parce que c'est de l'eau
calcaire sur un compteur c'est sûr que
ce n'est pas normal qu'aujourd'hui même
s'il faut dire aussi comment cela ce
n'est pas normal que des personnes
restent plusieurs journées sans eau
dans certaines communes ils dépeignent
donc c'est regrettable
moi je pense que l'urgence
ça n'était pas forcément le passé par
texte la société texte d'exception d'une
part d'autre part l'autre chose c'est
que les oies loupé un tout ce qu'ils ont
besoin
en dépit de toutes les considérations
politiques et politiciennes aussi ils
ont besoin d'avoir de l'eau et c'est ça
l'urgence et moi je m'inscris dans cette
logique là donc j'aime bien parce que
faire quelque soit le format les
premiers pourtant c'est le qu'on puisse
faire les travaux nécessaires et de
pouvoir donner de l'eau aux personnes
qui en ont besoin
une question de la part de thomas qui
vous demande ce que vous pensez de la
suppression de la chaîne france ô
est-ce que selon vous reparle assez de
l'outre-mer dans les trouve que c'est
insuffisant insuffisante ou que ce n'est
pas suffisant sur les autres chaînes
parce que la diversité de chaîne et
c'est très regrettable que ces comptes
liés à des problèmes d'actualité et
quelquefois ni pour les négatifs alors
qu'il ya beaucoup de choses et pour
tenter des choses positives qui se font
à tous les niveaux c'est vrai qu'il ya
les problèmes d'oreille à se tourner le
problème et je suis là pour vous dire
que je suis très impliquée dans la vie
mois de l'opn et pour me dire et même
anti âge mais malheureusement certaines
chaînes ne parle de la guadeloupe de la
martinique quand il ya des personnes et
biens dans la rue quand il ya un certain
nombre de faits divers et alors qu'il ya
des choses exceptionnelles maintenant
c'est vraiment dommage que compte tenu
de la situation sanitaire au niveau
culturel y ait moins d'événements mais
aussi au niveau que le tueur il ya
beaucoup de choses et jamais on ne voit
sur les chaînes certaines chaînes
nationales ce que
ce que nous nous produisons ce que nous
avons et nos hantises parce que nous
avons aussi un certain nombre d'artistes
de grande qualité de valeur et qu'ils ne
sont malheureusement pas suffisamment
visibles comme on dit alors il ya eu un
rapport qui a été fait en 2019 par le
sénat la délégation très bien justin a
fait un rapport sur l'audiovisuel
laissons le maire et il ya eu pour la
prière
lire après midi justement une première
évaluation de ce qui a été mis en place
par les france télévisions donc la
directrice madame gengoul elle est venue
il ya eu certain nombre de personnes qui
ont donné des indications elle a montré
que certain nombre d'engagements sont
déjà faire pas suffisamment sans doute
mais il y a une démarche qui commence
qui commençait hier au sénat la une et
c'est la dessinatrice qui avait été
court à porter ce rapport madame justin
guidel et l'autre à porter sites est
monsieur le sénateur antiste maurice
antiste la martinique
eh bien madame qui des spécialistes ont
pour le moment à la martinique madame 10
10 a évidemment salué les efforts qui
avait commencé donc ce n'est pas encore
suffisant c'est vrai que mon l'a reconnu
parce qu avait également européen un
représentant de dire est d'usagé qui
était là monsieur ries bus qui lui aussi
disait qu'il y avait encore jamais à
faire mais je crois sincèrement que pour
le moment même si des efforts sont faits
par france télévisions ce n'est pas
suffisant et je le souhaitais vraiment
qu'il y ait moi je ne suis pas là pour
parler les minorités visibles n'y a rien
du tout je parle du main on y lit à on
est sur un territoire national on doit
pouvoir montrer ce qui se fait en
polynésie ce qui se fait à mayotte ce
qui se fait en guyane guadeloupe en fait
dans tout sur l'ensemble des territoires
et pas seulement quand il y a
et comment je désire des événements
forcément négatif et dévalorisant et
comme quelquefois je le vois donc voilà
l'omi vous demande ce que vous pensez
des aides de l'état au niveau du
tourisme pour les outre-mer est ce que
c'est suffisant vous demande-t-il ou
est-ce que vous souhaitez d'autres z
il y avait le tourisme il ya eu il ya eu
des aides de l'état pour le tourisme la
difficulté aujourd'hui c'est que
beaucoup d'établissements ne peuvent pas
fonctionner donc les aides
il y a eu des excès vrai il faut
maintenir au niveau dambre même quand il
n'y a pas beaucoup de touristes mais il
faut quand même entretenir entretenir le
parfois la partie pour l'habitat mais
enfin tout autour ce qui contribue en
tout cas au bien être du tout risque
potentiel donc les établissements
fonctionnent plus ou moins avec une
population qui n'est pas en mesure
forcément au niveau local d'aller dans
certaines thèses il faut le dire
et ces aides alors moi je ne saurais
évaluer si elles sont suffisantes ou pas
d'une temps pas moi-même dans cette
branche
mais ce qui est que j'entends il que je
sais c'est que les professionnels
auraient souhaité qu'il n'y ait pas les
mesures qui ont été prises concernant
les les les déplacements concernant les
déplacements sur sur nos territoires
donc il ya eu des ailes je pense que là
il ya eu des aides meilleurs lycées eu
aussi des prêts garantis par l'état et
je sais qu'il ya un certaines des
entreprises qui contribuent en tout cas
à la prise en compte et la prise en
charge des touristes comme la situation
ne 5 millions pas forcément pour elles
ont des difficultés pour les échéances
donc je sais qu'il ya eu a été différé
ce n'est pas toujours toujours évident
parce qu'il ya un personnel et il ya
aussi tous ceux qui qui travaille pas
directement mais de façon indirecte
aussi avec les touristes
parce qu'il ya des agriculteurs qu'il
faut laisser les produits frais il y à
un certain nombre de personnels qui en
fonction des saisons et en fonction des
périodes travail
obhrai pas qu'ils sont arabes des
saisonniers il y avait toute une série
de conséquences le dirait on
hormis le fait qu'il y ait peut-être c
est de là mais ces sept pays surtout à
payer peut-être les frais fixes
inférences étonnant de dépenses j'ai une
dernière question pour vous qui est
posée par par veille vers wolf eva rolf
pardon qui vous demandent comment est ce
que vous envisagez le rapport entre la
métropole et les antilles dans une
logique bas carbone avec moins d'avions
moins de bateaux à moteur un peu en fait
il faut maîtriser alors il ya deux
niveaux et à deux niveaux la question
est posée parce que effectivement il
faut il maîtriser faire effectivement en
sorte qu'on ne l'utilisions beaucoup
alors les biocarburants on peut faire et
j'ai vu une expérimentation déjà j'étais
demande d'une mission d'une mission
d'information sur les transports aériens
et j'ai vu j'ai eu l'occasion de visiter
les endroits et j'ai su également qu'il
y avait du biocarburant qui te lisent
une expérimentation sur les vols
internes ici alors je ne sais pas il ya
des mélanges qui se font tous le
kérosène est là et ont progressivement
ils vont donc il ya des expérimentations
qui sont faites
donc moi je crois qu'il faut travailler
davantage mais il faut que la france
aussi finances suffisamment la recherche
dans ce domaine là pour permettre
évidemment qu'on puisse avoir avoir dit
des possibilités alternatives
moi je suis assez d'accent cole
alternatives à l'avion non non non c'est
pas à l'avion
non non non j'ai parlé des biocarburants
pascal egloff on a les couilles qui
viennent on a dit oui on allait battre
s'il fait bon il ya dix ans donc moi
donc c'est surtout non je ne parlais pas
la langue pendante non mais je dis que
c'est les alternatives à au kérosène
actuelle et là je ne parlais des
expérimentations qui sont en cours avec
d'autres types de d'autres types de
carburants les au bio les biocarburants
donc là c'est cela pour les battre moi
je crois qu'il faut optimiser davantage
celle qui est maman de rotation et
s'assurer que quand un bateau part au
camp de kango passe par conséquent soir
le niveau aérien ou alors maritime et
bien qu'il soit suffisamment rempli à la
limite de ce qui peut en tout cas
accueillir pour éviter autant de
rotation donc ça c'est la pire des
choses et maintenant on le voit bien
brossé ce qu'il ya moins de personnes
qui voyagent donc les avions les vols
sont sans cesse reportées
moi je le vis et 15 ans du co vide en
l'occurrence mais là peut-être oui là
c'est peut-être maîtriser ce à dire
limiter le nombre de vols est bon il ya
beaucoup de compagnies il faut que
toutes les compagnies vive parce qu'il
ya le côté social en même temps par
rapport aux pairs au personnel donc il
ya ça donc on a essayé de maîtriser en
tout cas les différentes limites et
peut-être le nombre de rotations et
maîtriser les choses afin que qui est
moins de moyens humains bien même on est
arrivé 1 5 où tout doit être mis en
question parce que la pandémie nous
montre que notre façon de consommer y
compris dans les transports est bien est
différente et je crois que ce sera remis
en question dans la mesure où maintenant
on voit qu'il ya des personnes qui se
déplacent par exemple pour certaines
réunions
régulièrement et bien il ya les réunions
qui pourront désormais probablement se
faire vision et en visio en visio il y a
également par exemple pour ce qui nous
concerne il ya un certain nombre de
travaux qui se font en visio et en
présentiel et dans l'hémicycle par
exemple ce qui concerne le sénat tout le
monde ne peut pas y est ensemble mais on
a peut être que présent dans certains
cas est bon et pour les votes alors pour
les fêtes à mes yeux n'est pas forcément
là et pour certes et vote il ya le
scrutin public qui s'applique et pour
lesquelles on a eu des ligues en date
d'une délégation de l'ong à son chef de
file merci beaucoup
victoire j'espère seulement qu'ils se
démerdent expression c'est moi qui vous
dira merci merci à vous merci à vous
d'avoir suivi cette invitation et je
vous dis à très bientôt sur public sénat
ciao merci
[Musique]
non